it's like an outlet for hate and
aggression
and they're unaware like they're doing
it with this
like veil of honor like we're doing it
for good
we're we're changing the world but in my
opinion i think that
if they really wanted to do real change
like you got to do it with love like
it's been you know done before
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast we have og cast members oh my
goodness
it's been so long joseph a japanese
akesek
bring that mic up a little closer to you
oh yeah hello man how's it going dude
it's been so long dude
you were in jersey doing mushroom things
yup
this is the most random [ __ ] like if you
guys ever follow joe on instagram
you'll never know what you're gonna find
out like you know because of like corona
thing everybody was kind of separated
out for a little bit and i would just
get updates through
instagram story and the next thing you
know i see this one growing mushrooms in
his [ __ ] living room
i know it's freaking crazy i'm actually
like in partnership with a mushroom farm
now and like
i've been saying man i i want that farm
life i just came back i was driving
tractors
i was [ __ ] riding pickup trucks and
everything
this was a breakup did wonders for him
no more
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] sugar cane fight is uh no
more no it's happening man people
thought i've been like just joking
around and i'm like nah dude i'm getting
into the farm life like
it's gonna start with mushrooms and then
i'm gonna build something out in hawaii
like it's gonna happen
is it is it pretty uh easy to grow
mushrooms yeah i'll
hook you up with one i'll show you how
to do it in everything i want to [ __ ]
make mushrooms because the way that it's
done so uh the number one
crop is shiitake yeah and and the
mushroom farm that i went to they do
oyster mushrooms and they do
like they're gonna start doing maitake
and all that stuff but
uh shiitake is like their number one
thing and you know like
shiitake is a part of japanese korean
chinese cooking like we
we grew up on that [ __ ] but the way that
it grows
is on wood man like in nature it grows
on wood like this
oh it doesn't grow on like in a in like
loamy soil or dirt
no it doesn't it grows on wood like it
it
so like if like i don't know like the
spores get on
the the branch or whatever right and
then like it uses that
for nutrients oh what the [ __ ] yeah
that's so interesting because
because right now ever since uh covet
i've been trying to grow my own [ __ ]
yeah right so i got two little [ __ ]
tomatoes coming out
and those two tomatoes are going to be
the most delicious thing ever but
because of that i'm that's why i'm
itching right now because i'm just
getting beginning
yeah you know what and because we live
like five minutes away but
ever since like okay so when it hits
sundown
if you if you're in your backyard or
anything there's a wave of mosquitoes
that come
that's exactly what happened because if
you do it in the hot sun in the midday
it's fine i got [ __ ] up because last
night i was just checking the soil to
see if it was
if it was moist or some [ __ ] this [ __ ]
might bore the [ __ ] out of you but you
have no idea ever since coveted i've
been like picking up random hobbies and
specifically gardening is one of them
so you have to check to see if the if
the soil is moist because it's been hot
and weird
and i was out there for maybe 10 minutes
and i got bit the [ __ ] up dude i have
like
maybe 12 mosquito bites bison right now
dude you'd be surprised like
no [ __ ] a lot of people are getting into
gardening and millennials
are the biggest uh group right now at 30
percent
oh really yeah it's the biggest emerging
group of um
gardening like people are really trying
to connect to nature
we're just there's something so human
about it like growing your own food
touching it feeling it watching it and
then you just like i didn't even have to
pay for this [ __ ]
that's the i never thought that i would
enjoy
gardening as much just because when i
would see my parents do it i'm like
that's some [ __ ] old people
really you never did it with your
grandpa like it was to me it's nostalgic
because i used to garden white let me
tell you something
the only thing that i know about
gardening is that my mom when she would
fight with my dad she would go ahead and
hide in a squash patch
she would pretend like she ran away and
then she would hide in the squash patch
and the next day she went 40 mosquito
bites on her [ __ ] face oh my god
that's what i know about gardening but
my mom has always had a green thumb
she grows a bunch of our [ __ ] like even
at home i have a bunch of squash that i
got a bunch of plums from
our plum tree but i never tried growing
it myself number one i thought it was
very difficult
which it kind of is at first if you
think like gardening is just
putting a seed in the earth and then you
just walk away for a lot of things it is
yeah yeah but you're right it's a little
bit more than that yeah it's it's a
little more difficult specifically when
it comes to
the the type of vegetables that you're
growing and it's interesting because
like it's not like my mom looked this
stuff up on google or whatever
by the stuff that she learned because
she grew up in the chico area which is
like the farm rural area
so she knew how to grow [ __ ] and then
you know she was teaching me how to
make sure the soil is nice and moist not
to over water it because you go over
water plants you could underwater plants
uh
if if you don't have enough fertilizer
if you have put too much fertilizer
it'll die
[ __ ] these things man that's tight but
that's why i have too much
two uh two tomatoes growing right now
just two it's just [ __ ] too good to
turn red yet
no well these ones are uh these yellow
zebra
varieties oh so they're they're yellow
and they have green stripes in them yeah
yeah but
i have i'm gonna eat the [ __ ] out of
those two things
it's gonna sweet it's gonna take [ __ ]
another two months for them to mature
some like a month or so
well i mean once it starts going though
by next year it'll probably be like
going yeah because now that i understand
how to grow like i didn't know either
because in
in our area right now there aren't a lot
of bees so i actually have to pollinate
the flowers
myself and so the like tomato plants
people are like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
listen to this [ __ ] i've been studying
this for two months i don't give a [ __ ]
what you guys want to listen to
i had to i found out that tomato plants
um if the bees won't pollinate them
they're actually self-pollinating so all
you have to do is shake the the flowers
and the pollen will they'll cross
pollinate that way and then fruits
and then eggplants if there aren't any
bees around the male and the female
parts are within the flower so you just
have to take a q-tip
and then rub the female part pollen into
the male part which is the middle of the
stamen
uh middle part is a stamen and so i
didn't know that [ __ ] so all my flowers
were falling off
yeah so i i thought i was underwatering
that [ __ ] and then when i woke up the
other day i had like three eggplant
flowers that fell off
i was pissed because they were supposed
to be eggplants but i didn't pollinate
them that's why
i got bit by a hornet yesterday checking
on my fig plant
a hornet tree yeah what does that feel
like it
they attack you multiple times so like
they just get like
it's right here my [ __ ] cab is more
slow my ride is more swollen look at
that
yeah it's more swollen on the right
right it went right on my
[ __ ] um shin right there and then i
was just checking my figs
and then this hornet came and it just
went straight to my calf
and it bit me and i was like what the
[ __ ] and i and i kind of
swiped it off and then i was walking
around and it came back at me again and
i was it was around my ankle
and i was like the cartoon where you try
to run and you look for a [ __ ] lake
so you could jump in the water
i was like pat's staying with me right
now he's working out in the garage
and at the same time i was running
through that [ __ ] like hoping the the
hornet like
left me alone and yeah it [ __ ] sucked
it's weird
i now that uh now that i'm at home a lot
more um
because before i was traveling a lot
doing some foods or whatever uh number
one i'm getting to know the neighbors
more
and number two i get to hear all the
[ __ ] neighbor drama they're so old
i'm such an old person
yeah i'm listening to gossip i'm
listening to other people's drama and
i'm gardening now
that's tight so the next level is you
need to get a farm
so our neighbors next to me they're i
they're
either i think they're middle eastern
or something like that something of that
area but it's the funniest thing because
i'm listening to the father and the son
fight
almost every other morning right they
[ __ ] fight non-stop and it reminds me
of me and my dad when i was younger oh
really
right are they around your like when
you're younger i think he the the son is
probably in his mid-20s
and so i'm listening to that [ __ ] so
he's not that much younger than me but
listening to it i'm like [ __ ]
i kind of want to go over and count
counsel them it's like this is this is
not the way
but i've i've recorded it really on my
phone multiple times i'll show it to you
later but this literally
their conversations are the the constant
thing of
of a of an immigrant father not knowing
how to talk to his son
yeah because you know immigrants
immigrant dads are very aggressive with
what they say
yeah how they say they just say you're
stupid exactly straight up
yeah so that's how the dad talks to the
sun
and so the sun gets [ __ ] fed up with
it so just the other day i woke up to
this conversation and i [ __ ] you not
it was him saying you know what your
problem is is you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] every morning
i'm trying to work
i'm saving up money to make sure you and
mom are going to be
secure when you're older i'm working my
[ __ ] at what have you ever said good
job
have you ever told me good job oh [ __ ]
you know and so he's asking for approval
yeah and then you see the mom just
trying to get in between them
yeah she's just like please please no
fighting no fighting
i feel so bad for her because she's
trying to be the mediator yeah she goes
just go inside
don't don't yell don't yell at the
father just please go inside are they
fighting outside
uh they're fighting outside so the whole
neighbors can hear everything and the
dad's like i don't want you in this
house i'm gonna take your clothes i'm
gonna leave it on the ping pong table
how would you get the [ __ ] out of here
that's telling me to get the [ __ ] out
and he's like oh [ __ ] dude and she go
see even grandma knows how you talk to
me grandma doesn't like the way you talk
to me he goes what the [ __ ] does she
know what does grandma know i take care
of everything
they're screaming at each other they do
this almost every other day
in this fight every day and it's always
about how the son doesn't like the way
the dad
talks to talks to him he's like
disrespect me too much
but the son too also doesn't really talk
to his dad very respectfully either
so they're kind of the same person yeah
so when i
the other day the the other day the week
before that
i heard the sun talking to the dad and
he was asking the dad to get him
something out of the garage
but the way he said it was hyper
aggressive right he was he was
so the dad was uh moving the ping pong
table because i'm on the
i'm on the top level i could see down so
the dad was cleaning up stuff and i woke
up because he was moving the ping pong
table scraping against the concrete
so that woke me up and i looked out the
window i'm like what's going on
dad's moving stuff he goes dad can you
get me the stuff out of the garage or
not
and it's like oh [ __ ] that's an attitude
problem it's about to pop
off so his dad looks at him he goes what
he goes why can't you get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of the [ __ ] garage
oh my god this is this is going to go
down so you go see you're always [ __ ]
disrespecting me
and i'm like bro you kind of
disrespected him first thing yeah
so they're kind of two of the same yeah
they're just blind to the way that they
treat each other
i can't i every at first it used to
annoy me and now i look forward to it
every other week
you know what the real problem is is
that ping pong table yeah they gotta get
ready they gotta get rid of people dude
yeah what the [ __ ] that's funny man and
then the the night before that
uh i have a neighbor uh really super
nice guy
and i actually talked to him before i
left um but i guess after i left
marielle texted me she goes
dude something's going on over there i'm
like what are you talking about another
neighbor so the other neighbor that's uh
right next to me
yeah um so there's our unit complex and
then there's houses next to us
this the first neighbor that i'm talking
about is the house next to me okay this
is my unit neighbor
and i guess [ __ ] was being thrown things
were being busted
people were screaming at the top of
their lungs like a [ __ ]
family fight yeah or something like that
because but it was weird because i just
spoke with the guy and he was in the
best mood
ever and then you put him in a bad mood
no no no
we were just chopping it up we were
talking about the new ford bronco that
was coming out he was super excited
because he just put a down payment on it
oh [ __ ]
and then lo and behold i leave and then
mario's like dude i think they're
getting into like
almost like a fist fight because they
heard like [ __ ] being
busted and thrown and i was kind of
shocked because those two people are
like the nicest human beings ever
because they were having rough sex
what i actually found out was that his
wife is korean i was like of course
so he was getting in trouble i get i
don't know what it is but i just i was
like
he was in a perfectly good mood before
but then once the korean thunder came in
it [ __ ] it all up but he uh yeah so
[ __ ] funny yeah so all of our
neighbors were texting each other and
they were asking me you guys have a
group chat yeah
so they're like yo did you hear what was
going on yesterday a group chat without
him
without him because they were they
weren't sure they were it
it sounded like somebody was getting
their ass being what it sounded like but
but she was beating his ass i don't know
but no one knows
i know that the guy left oh [ __ ] so he
i actually just saw him before i came
here yeah and i saw him in his car and
he didn't park it in the lot he parked
it outside so i'm like yeah
did he get his ass beat oh yeah i'm
thinking like did he get [ __ ] up
damn i'm trying to figure out that
mystery right now so
your whole life's just been reality tv
with the neighbors yep
i've always said the best reality tv is
reality oh 100 like a lot of the [ __ ]
that we can't talk about
a lot of the things that we know behind
the scenes
of your favorite youtubers all that [ __ ]
i think that is better entertainment
than some [ __ ] you watch on tv the the
the social media life recently has been
so weird because
um i think now it you can't really keep
secrets
right so everybody that kind of put out
a persona that they were this perfect
human being
uh you kind of [ __ ] yourselves over
because all your personal stuff is now
coming out to light because people can
search and dig it up there's stories
that are
that people have told about you and
because you guys weren't honest about
who you were in the first place
now you're getting [ __ ] over yup it's
sad but in our case
we've been scoundrels
you can't [ __ ] with me i'm already who i
am like you've been knowing
yeah i put it out there i cancel myself
before anybody else can
[ __ ] that was the dope thing i think um
one of the things i was very proud about
or not i
wouldn't say proud but we've always kind
of stuck to who we were
and even if we did have to apologize for
stuff there's no sweat off our back it's
like
you know we've made mistakes in the past
and if it if those mistakes in the
in the past weren't mistakes then and
they are now and you feel a certain way
about it then i'm sorry
you know yeah i mean time keeps moving
forward and we keep growing and learning
but
i think we're a part of this culture
right now where like
no one is allowed to learn from their
mistakes
and they're not forgiven so like if i
[ __ ] up
when i was 15 and i said something
they're coming after me
yeah you know what i mean and and that's
kind of the unfortunate thing that's
happening to a lot of people
but on the flip side people aren't
getting away with [ __ ] like
yeah whole me too and all the [ __ ]
rapists and all these
you know even the epstein [ __ ] like
we're not letting that [ __ ]
go where in the past i think people
would just kind of let it
pass and just like well yeah it's kind
of what happens in hollywood or whatever
it's just too much of of of a blanket
punishment for everybody yeah yeah
it's it's not it's not fair but i think
it's just over correction
like what i what i see is like what
society looks like to me is like a
pendulum right
and then so you have one side
and it gets too crazy like for example
when you know world war
ii you had nazi in in in hitler like it
goes
so crazy to the point where like they're
killing people because of their race
right
and then it has to correct to the side
where it's super sensitive and europe is
at the point where they never want to do
that ever again
yeah but then it got to the point where
maybe it might be too liberal and there
is a thing where being too liberal is
also not good
yeah yeah it's weird because i'm always
i'm i'm trying to navigate the way i i
view things too right just because i
feel
like because i started off as a comic i
i can find any funny things in about
anything
and i've always said this too just
because something particularly
particularly offends me i've never
outright said
cancel this person make sure that they
don't have a living and they'll never
work again yeah that's the odd thing for
me right
i have an opinion and i make jokes about
how people are and how they behave
depending on who they are in their
current state you know um we talk i
talked about this on the podcast before
but there's this guy
uh he was a part of eater i think he
still is now but he had the show called
the
the meat show right and back in the day
he was a
he was a skinhead um he was a part of a
skinhead like punk band like a rock band
or whatever he had a swastika
all that [ __ ] yeah um would have never
known that [ __ ] now because
now when you see him um on his show the
meat show yeah
he's really close friends with asian
chefs people of all different cultures
very accepting very warm you know so he
kind of like
went through it and he learned his
lesson exactly this was in his like his
young 20s right
and so people were asking for him to be
removed from the show
and whatever and make a public apology
and in my mind
for being a part of a skinhead group
yeah in his 20s yeah
you know he's like in his 40s now or
something but what it's like
we all kind of did stupid [ __ ] when we
were young and we were like me like
i mean i did crime and i was a part of a
gang and like
should that always haunt me because
after that i learned so much about the
world and
absolutely changed as a person and i
think that everyone has that opportunity
to do that you know and it sucks that if
this guy is still being haunted
from what he did in the past or whatever
yeah because even people for example
like people that i like like eddie huang
eddie huang said that he should
yeah people should be forgiven for his
mistakes but he still should be fired
and i completely disagree with that and
i [ __ ] with eddie huang a lot you know
he should be fired because of why though
like what's their argument
i don't know that's the thing i think
his i think eddie huang i mean he did a
post about it on instagram but he was
talking about how
um yeah he may have gotten better
whatever what not
but he still should lose his job and he
could continue his job elsewhere
but it's like for what though but if he
got a job elsewhere and then
he gets cancelled every single time
that's like
really um you know he he did the time he
paid the crime or
he learned his lesson but then he didn't
get no one's accepting it like no one's
accepting that he's grown from it
basically that's what it says right and
it's just a cyclical issue right because
you know we could even go ahead and talk
about the whole kevin hart issue when he
when he made those old stand-up jokes
and people were saying that he was
perpetuating um
uh you know violence against the
homosexual community right
but if you look at a lot of stuff too
i'll i'll bring up uh
eddie murphy eddie murphy used to say
[ __ ] in his
stand-up sets all the time yeah during
that time that was a funny word
right it was a funny word he said all
this other stuff uh people in the crowd
they were
dying [ __ ] laughing so if you're
saying that a majority of people were
offended
in that stadium of like four thousand
five thousand people were crying
laughing from his jokes
it's a representation of the times times
have changed and even eddie murphy now
he uh he did an interview where he was
talking about some of the jokes that he
said against like the
like the lgbt community and he regrets
it he goes at the time i
i thought it was funny and i look back
at it now and it makes me cringe it
makes me feel terrible yeah the times
change
yeah and and what sucks is that right
now we're judging the past
based off of our current morals
and to me that doesn't make any sense
like you got to do it
in perspective of that era yeah and to
me it's not a question of right or wrong
it's about
understanding and having empathy for
example right like
a lot of people will try to make the
excuse and they'll be like well
it was fine because back then it was
okay and then they try to be excused but
i think that
that's where people get pissed because
it's like it's not about that man we
just want you to understand that that's
not okay anymore right
and i think you can have that
conversation but to really look at
someone and being like
for example like asians weren't always
the greatest
um like we weren't all we didn't always
have the greatest roles in hollywood
right
yeah but it's almost like blaming an
asian actor
who played a role of a racist character
and you're just like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] backstabbing [ __ ] like you're
such a two-faced like
oh i can't believe you're such a race
trader like it's almost like saying
those things to that actor
when that was the only opportunity that
they had and at that time
you know no one was even thinking about
that like you know
so it's it's to me i'm like
it's also a lot of people who haven't
lived life i think a lot of people
who have a lot of judgment a lot of like
hate and anger towards
like injustice and and whatever
especially young folk right like they
haven't made a lot of mistakes in life
so i remember i had a really high
sense of justice to this point where
like i would be like i can't believe
that these people
uh can't hold a marriage together
because they're so [ __ ] selfish and
they want to cheat or like
you condemn people for their actions and
you don't have
any type of empathy for people making
mistakes and i think that's
what's kind of dangerous about um
in my opinion it's the youth right
because like they haven't
lived all the way they haven't made that
many mistakes
they have formulated arguments and
thoughts
but that hasn't been tested like sure
they've
lived up to a certain point but like we
all know people
who made tremendous mistakes and then
the more years you are on this earth
you're gonna make a [ __ ] ton more
and you're gonna reflect back and and it
just makes more sense to understand
like and use this experiment that we're
all going through
as a way to go like okay like we're
humans and we keep making mistakes let's
learn from it but the point is to move
on and like
talk about it instead of just being like
oh this guy
he's a nazi but you know afterwards he
changed he he learned whatever but he
still can't work
anywhere for the rest of his life yeah
it's like the same thing you know like
what if someone was a gang member a lot
of gang members are
treated that way like yeah it sucks
because
i mean i think like a big question too
for people who want to condemn somebody
for the rest of their life and drag them
right
and i think it's easy for you when
you're sitting there and you're behind a
keyboard right
because you're not out in the spotlight
but i guarantee you if i look deep
enough and i looked into your [ __ ]
skeletons in your closet
you have probably done way worse things
or you have done stuff that's comparable
to what they've done
every single that's why it's like the
bible is like he who who cast the first
tone
yeah you know make sure you don't got no
[ __ ]
crack in your system either you know and
and it's in it
and it's so easy to do this like
remember that kid he um
he was judging that white girl for
wearing that chinese dress oh yeah i
mentioned that
basically bullied her saying like don't
make my [ __ ] culture your costume and
all this stuff
and like this is racist and all that and
then what we find out
is that he was using the n-word he was
saying racist things
yeah with against black people and for
me i'm like man
i don't know like who who are these
people who are
like so judgmental so angry so hateful
and they think that they're not hateful
but what they're doing
in cancel culture like condemning others
and like coming in and just i it's
almost like it's almost like this right
like
for me i feel like oh if this guy was a
[ __ ] child molester a serial killer
it's okay i could dexter him i could
[ __ ] kill his ass right
and i get to fulfill my killer fantasies
because
i'm killing a bad guy i'm killing a
demon i'm not killing a human being
and i think that's kind of what's
happening in our society right now where
people
are like these justice warriors right
and they're like
well this person's a bad person so i can
talk as much [ __ ] and put them in their
place
so they're really it's like an outlet
for hate and aggression
and they're unaware like they're doing
it with this
like veil of honor like we're doing it
for good
we're changing the world but in my
opinion i think that
if they really wanted to do real change
like you got to do it with love like
it's been you know done before with mlk
and and gandhi and all the greatests but
no one does that path right everyone
wants to destroy
and and like sure they're not physically
violent
but their actions and they're motivated
by
a negative feeling which ends up turning
into destruction like when you're just
hatefully expressing when you're going
into these people's dms and just talking
mad [ __ ] [ __ ] like you're not
creating change you're not informing
anyone
there's no justice happening it's just
spilling anger out i mean it's
it's almost like some of these kids like
they get like a hard-on for the [ __ ]
yeah i think so because they get public
praise for right they're like you love
this you know one of the things too
you called them out you did this yeah it
was like when i when i was doing
those you know those rant videos right
that's what i used to do back in the day
all the time
it's like it's serious talk but there's
a lot of comedy it's me roasting the
[ __ ] out of somebody right
um and a lot of people have been
wondering like you haven't done one of
those videos in a long time
that [ __ ] eats away at my soul like it's
not it's not something that i thoroughly
enjoy
hunting for people yeah to make their
life miserable i mean you did it
sporadically when
you felt the motivation exactly because
you just saw some injustice and you're
just like
well let me roast this [ __ ] because
what they're doing is it doesn't go
along with what i think
and so you know we did like five or six
videos on that right
and they're you know people are waiting
for more it's like you have to
understand
that [ __ ] if i'm not passionate about
the subject or the topic at hand right
now
i did five or six of them it's just me
being repetitive and i'm just kind of
using this just to
it makes me feel like i'm using
something very important to gain fame
from it
and i i don't want that because now the
intention is is not
on what's going on here it's it's about
me so it makes me feel very weird you
know and
one of these kids too i've i've even
messaged them i was like hey if you want
me to take my video down
just apologize and then i'll remove it
easy stuff
yeah he told me to [ __ ] off and i was
like cool okay and then he deleted his
whole thing so i'm like i
you know it's not like i'm out here to
ruin your [ __ ] life bro but you put
out a public statement
um some a very disrespectful and racist
public statement yeah so i put one out
to disrespect you back that's all that
it is
and then now you can't take the heat
yeah well you're the one who brought it
upon yourself yeah nobody asked you to
say these public opinions on a public
forum in that type of way
you know which is the odd thing which i
want people to understand like when we
when we
put stuff out you have to realize if
it's not perceived the way that you want
it that's not
their everybody else's fault yeah the
public gets to perceive whatever they
want to perceive right
that's that's their choice it's your job
to communicate things clearly
yeah and if the majority don't
understand you you're the
problem yeah and there was uh
so there was that girl who called the
cops
on um uh the black guy in
new york where he was a the bird watcher
i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so she yeah i thought that she's gonna
be in like
in she's going to court or something
she's creating a law behind
everything yeah what about it so even
for him when he was saying
uh i saw an interview that he wrote that
he was um
not nothing he wrote but he was in an
interview where he was saying that
the purpose of this he doesn't want her
life to be ruined he doesn't want her
not to be able to get a job again and
none of that stuff he just he was
correcting an injustice like this wasn't
right
yeah you know so when we had this
conversation even for him he's not here
doing it out of a place of
of hate it's just more like this is
wrong
i need to correct it and for him he
didn't
particularly enjoy how people were
attacking her you know he goes i don't
think you should attack her per se
but this should be highlighted and this
should be a problem that's fixed she has
every every person that has [ __ ] up
recently in that type of sense has an
ability to change in the future
yeah 100 and i think for me too i have
to really think about
okay how can i if it's really that
important to me
how can i make this person change for
the better uh if
if i want them to yeah you know but
sometimes people need a good roasting
oh for sure i feel like some of these
[ __ ] if they didn't get called
out in the in the first place like that
dude who was out in
uh monterey oh the one that was the the
british guy that was talking [ __ ] to the
filipino family yeah
that guy is a [ __ ] dude he dug his
grave even further you know that
after his public apology he got caught
talking [ __ ] like i didn't even mean it
anyway
oh my god yeah dude [ __ ] that guy you
know what's so funny he's like get out
of this country it's like [ __ ] you're
not even you're an immigrant
like you're not even american like shut
the [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] is he talking
not even a citizen dude the [ __ ] is he
talking about yeah it's crazy
he was he's not even an american dude
he's like okay i'm like
let can we deport can we deport this guy
because we don't want him here
what in the [ __ ] yeah so after that he
it was another public statement or did
somebody out him out because he was like
uh
yeah so it was um he was outed because
you know people were talking to him in
the dms and
and he would just talk [ __ ] right back
and then they screenshotted it
then they've it's been everywhere that's
why some of these these public apologies
people don't want them anymore they want
to see action instead so it's like okay
cool
you you wrote a public apology that's
fine but let's see
put your uh your money where your mouth
is let's see it in the
in in what you contribute to how you go
about things
you know the rhetoric that you have
because his partner's korean dude his
business partners korean oh what the
[ __ ]
his uh i think his brother's wife is
asian
my people yeah well they probably might
have not known or maybe they're getting
bullied by this guy like we don't know
yeah this podcast is brought to you by
fiverr my friends
have you ever needed freelance work that
was reliable but you just couldn't find
it well that's because
you haven't heard of fiverr 2020 has
been a year of
uncertainty so how can your business
plan for the unexpected well guess what
you do that by hiring reliable freelance
work to get stuff done that you can't
get done
fiverr's online marketplace connects
businesses with freelancers offering
hundreds of digital services including
graphic design
copywriting web programming film editing
and a bunch more i've used fiverr for a
whole bunch of stuff like
if i ever need a website stuff to be
done on the fly and i don't have time to
do it or
there's certain things that i don't know
how to do i always hit up fiverr the
pricing is there it's
i don't have to negotiate anything um
there's plans to
when it will be delivered and it's
always been delivered on time and it's
just been a really easy experience for
me
finding freelance work so check it out
guys check out fiverr.com and receive 10
off your first order by using my code
gb find all the digital services you
need in one place
at f i v e r r dot com
code gb again that's fiverr.com
code gb but it's just uh it's just weird
but this guy's a scumbag man he has
multiple duis like he just
this is he's like i don't know for me
like people that are constantly drinking
and driving like
i feel like they don't give a [ __ ] about
the world
the people that are like that when i see
because some other people have been
sending me videos of
uh guys and girls who or let's say men
and women who
have been doing a lot of these racist
rants but you look at them and they look
mentally unstable yeah it's like what
who am i roasting for like what is the
purpose of this this person is a
mentally unstable person most of them
are dude
yeah it's it doesn't like they're not a
good representation of like
the norm yeah like so that's why i'm
just like don't look at them and think
this is how white people are
like we're we're stooping down to the
level of racists if we think that
a whole group of people is represented
by this one dumb [ __ ]
there's been some weird conversations
where i had to
uh i've been reading seeing a lot of
stuff on twitter where people are saying
um i mean a lot of like
that uh only white people can be racist
which is a very
weird thing for me to hear a lot i get
what it means
where did that come from like i so in um
it comes from basically
like i would say liberal thinking
and um in sociology
they the if you want to get specific
right when when you think in layman's
terms when you think
racism all you think about is hate
toward
one group yeah but what they've done is
they specified it where
white people can be or you can be
prejudiced like black people can be
prejudiced against
white people but white people cannot be
uh
racist against black people or wait oh
the other way around yeah
yeah yeah yeah so white people can't be
race uh yeah racist because
the term racism is meant for
a dominant majority who is running [ __ ]
so then if technically if you're a
minority
and you don't really run [ __ ] in this
country or anything then
you you're technically not able to be
caught uh
you can't be racist is that like
definition or interpretation it's a
debatable definition but is
basically a lot of these like social
thinkers that's where they came up with
that
concept where like yeah so they're so i
i
get it but i think we also have to
understand how
people use the word racism is just
hating one
race yeah that's that's how we all use
it so i think that there's just a mix up
because like
you know there's a lot of words where
the specific meaning
in like academia or in other places
might mean something different
but then in the way that like everyday
people use it is different so that's why
it gets confusing yeah because that's
very confusing for me
when i when i kept hearing that over and
over because i
to me racism is just a sub category
of being prejudiced against somebody
right so
if you hate somebody specifically based
on their race or the color of their skin
whether it be white brown
whatever whatever that it is you still
can be racist
you know if we're talking about uh like
us like systemic racism i think that's a
that's a different subject but i think
in racism in general if you look at a
white person say i [ __ ] hate you
because the color of your skin
makes you a racist yeah tim you know
sounds pretty racist yeah
that sounds pretty [ __ ] random people
go through racism and like you know i
met a guy who was um
he grew up in the islands in the
caribbean and
he was the only like white kid on that
island
and you know he got picked on and that
happens to a lot of white kids in hawaii
you know like
it's not a mystery or it's not even a
secret that
a lot of white kids that grow up in
hawaii are picked on
um and beat up and they had even this
thing called holly day where they would
just
[ __ ] up all the white kids yeah so um
i think anywhere in the world if you're
kind of the minority or the only kid in
the town that's different or whatever
like you're gonna get bullied and i'm
not saying that this is good or bad or
whatever it's just
it's just kind of human nature like we
tend to pick on things that are
different from us like
it's very tribal and i think the goal to
me is to elevate
everybody from being
this kind of primitive human being to
being
next level in kind of
at that point you don't see people in
categories and you don't see people in
colors and
us versus them you know like you see
them as like
oh this intelligent being that just so
happens to have a different looking
vessel yeah but a lot of people can't do
that you know
it's because we even see that in in the
animal kingdom right because you'll see
um like for example you'll see a pack of
animals you'll see this all the time
on on nature channel where you see a
pack of animals and there's
one animal that has like albinism in it
yeah and then that
animal tends to be pushed aside they're
not allowed part of the pack and they
push him out
and i feel like humans at the at the the
core of us we're still animals
but then we should be elevated and smart
enough to understand that
you know we should be a little more
inclusive than that and it's true though
like the majority always pushes out the
minority
and no matter what case it's just kind
of sad that when um
people in this country they're not
allowed a lot of the things that other
people have because of it so
it makes it a huge issue it's kind of a
good time for me to plug in
my relaunch of the 90 days to freedom
because we're on the topic of
mentality and all that but um i launched
this thing in january right i got about
like
1000 students and the whole experiment
was to see if all of like you know like
we see eye to eye on a lot of things and
it's because
we've been through very similar
experiences owning our own businesses
like you know being on youtube being in
the public eye all this stuff right
and i'm like my experiment was how do i
speed up this process
for our audience or for someone who's
always been
you know looking up to us and but they
don't know what the right things to do
like
they don't they're not provided with the
right tools the only difference is
really from us in the audience is the
way we think yeah
not much is different right like if
unless they're extremely poor
or like super disabled physically or
mentally or whatever like
as long as you have an average
intelligence a lot of things that we're
doing
is highly achievable and sure it's
easier said you know
you can look at us and be like well it's
because you guys started youtube early
or you
you know you have all the right
networking or whatever but
that i don't really agree with because
it knocks down
our work like how hard we worked how
much rejection we got how many mistakes
we
made how much money we lost like all
these things
it just basically when you call somebody
lucky you're not really saying that
they did anything yeah to get where
they're at right
and i'm not saying like i'm this mega
millionaire or anything but
but for me i find a lot of passion in
and
teaching this and for me i wanted to
figure out if i could create a system
where i can get everything that i
learned in the last 10 years
and then like condense it and um that's
where 90 days to freedom was kind of
born
and and we did this in january and now
you know things didn't really turn out
the way that we thought in 2020 like
rona like a lot of crazy [ __ ] happened
but the few that really stuck with
it what ended up happening was some
crazy [ __ ] man there's guys that like
cleared their debt
there's people that like worked out all
these issues with their family members
that they've
been putting away for like 15 years like
there's so many things that went down
and the whole concept is like it's not
some
get rich scheme you know like it's not
really about like
making a ton of money or anything like
that but literally
the whole concept of like being free
right when you hear that word
i think most people go like oh if if i
win the lotto
then i'll be free or if i finally find
the girl of my dreams i'll be free
because like i don't have to date
anymore or whatever right it's
it's this idea of like oh once i get
there
i won't have to do any struggles anymore
but how
real is that like it never works out
yeah
it's it's always goal chasing and then
you're still stressed out because
people out there i think
at least for me when i when i'm seeing
almost everyone around me and the
unsuccessful people like it's because
they're not
literally free in their minds like
they're constantly
in they're trapped in like their own
thoughts
yeah and i think that to unlocking that
became like this obsession of mine
and so i released this and i ran a
survey with the with the
alumni and all the students that took it
they're just like this is how you can
improve on it or whatever
we just have a 2.0 version out and i'm
gonna leave a link
in the description it's gonna it's gonna
explain much much more you can watch
that video but
if you you know if this resonates with
you you're probably
looking for something like this because
if you like genius brain and we talk
about this kind of stuff
all the time and you might be thinking
like how come joe and david like
think a certain way well i think we
think
more free than the average human being
that's probably why
but yeah i think uh go ahead and check
out that video but
yeah it's weird when yeah i don't i
don't know
i feel we i mean we've grazed on this
topic before
where there's this a lot of people
like to they kind of talk down to
themselves first
before anybody else gets to right so
before you guys even try something out
you already have a million reasons why
you can't do something and i think
that's the hardest part to break out of
because that's something that i still
struggle with a lot of the times too
it's not like when i say hey just go out
there and do something
verbally it's very simple right um and
you know when i had a
i had this guy his name was cosmo he was
a he was a dating guy
one of the things that he kind of said
that was a little profound and a lot of
people kind of agreed and disagreed with
what he was saying as somebody who's a
dating coach
but uh something that kind of resonated
with me that i really believe is that a
lot of the times when we tell somebody
just to do something
and we say that we have an answer for a
solution we never give somebody
specifics in the house like so
for example when he was saying that um
when a girl says this
when they when they give advice to
another guy about how to approach
a woman they go just be yourself no
well what the [ __ ] does that mean yeah
if somebody doesn't know
definitely what that is it's such a
broad thing to say right it's like
just be yourself or when you talk to
them talk about something
fun what is that if somebody hasn't done
that before they've never been in that
situation
or they're not they're not comfortable
with it how does somebody do it and
that's true because i've given that
advice too where i've told the guys like
hey just chill be relaxed and just you
know
just chop it up cool david how you know
especially if they have anxiety and they
don't know how to control that anxiety
like there's just so many things
and you're completely right man and i
think that's the whole
thing to me is like having a true like
free mind
is really not having that guilt that
insecurity
all those things that limit you yeah and
once you can
like get past that and you can be calm
about any situation
and you can work through your thoughts
to me that's the most liberating feeling
and
and you can be a millionaire you could
just make you could be broke but once
you have that
i think that that's really the recipe of
just
being happy yeah yeah but
i've seen it multiple times too where
people are like well
i have this dream and i want to make a
youtube channel and this and this and
then like they'll tell me
everything and then they go yeah but
here's the list of 10 excuses why they
can't do it
yeah and they're not good enough so i'm
like you wasted one hour
of just telling me your dream and then
shutting it all down and i didn't say
anything
and i think and i think the weird thing
is too is that when
when people want to try something new
they only want to try something new when
there's a guaranteed success at the end
of it yeah
and nothing is [ __ ] guaranteed yeah i
think it's just scary i think
the whole thing well for one i know why
people do it
um i know why people talk themselves
down and all that stuff but i think
uh it usually happens at an early age
where you feel some type of pain
emotional pain hurt regret for doing
and trying something out yeah or
you had someone close to you that hurt
your feelings because
they laughed at you they they kept
telling you that you can't do something
or you have a parent that is um
really fearful and they don't want to
see you hurt
emotionally or physically and then they
constantly
reinforce this thinking of
being a coward or being fearful of the
world don't do this don't do that don't
do that you're gonna fail you're not
gonna be able to make it right so like
when you have these controlling parents
that are constantly telling you that's
not gonna work that's risky whatever
it's kind of like brainwashing literally
you've been hearing this for the
for 10 years and then even though you
start becoming your own person
um you start forgetting how you got
programmed and then now you're in high
school
and you don't real like you're you're an
adult and you realize things
aren't as crazy as your mom says it is
she's just paranoid right but for you
you somehow cannot find the courage
because every time
you want to try something different
whatever your mom
did or your dad or whatever they
injected their fears
into you now so so people don't realize
like
that you're being constantly um
programmed
by the people around you yeah
one of the things too that i see a lot
of people do um and this is kind of more
on the negative side of things is
when they see other people do what they
want to do like they're kind of
i want to say fearless but they swallow
their fear and they pursue what they
want
yeah um they'll try to knock that person
down a lot
just because they can't do it themselves
yeah and it's easier for that person
just to be like oh you're not that dope
like you're not gonna be
you're not gonna succeed either way
because it makes them feel comfortable
when you're
kind of brought down to their level yeah
i think another fear that a lot of
people have is that when you
become successful and you start doing
better things that you can't
bring other people up with you but at
the end of the day that's also their
responsibility
you know they they have to take it in
their own hands to kind of be successful
with you
you'll see this a lot when you grow up
there's a lot of people that you're
going to grow up with and you're going
to separate from them
not because you hate them not because of
any of that stuff is simply just because
you guys grew apart you guys have
different goals and they're not in the
same part that you were
and if you're and if you're scared of
becoming successful because
you can't bring these other people along
you'll just be in that hole for the rest
of your life
you'll find like-minded people or you
might even inspire these other human
beings you don't really know
and i mean we went through that where we
had to shed some people
from our lives because uh you know you
try your best to
to to bringing them up but they're just
not ready or
they don't want you to help them you
know and it sucks like it's
heartbreaking because
you care about them and you want them to
do good but at the same time you
are your own person and you have your
own goals and if you
put others in front of you to that point
now you're hurting yourself yeah and
it's a balancing act man it's hard this
this whole game of life i think like
yeah you're right like there's a lot of
people out there that think that
just because you're successful it's a
reflection of them being unsuccessful
so they can't root for you and for me
i'm like well [ __ ] them i don't want
people like that around my life but
they'll try to take your success and say
the reason why you're successful is
because of them
remember that time i told you to be a
comedian that was all me
that was me [ __ ] yeah really
just one sentence of encouragement you
know
20 other people encouraged me too yeah
like i think i told the story before but
when i when i came to
la and this is years after i came here
and you know um youtube kind of sparked
my my career to kind of
open up and do other things um i got
this random
letter from a dude and
uh he was a comic as well and we were
doing comedy together
did he write a letter like he wrote a
handwritten it was it was through
facebook i believe it was because i was
like imagining somebody with a [ __ ]
quilt
he put out a [ __ ] feather pen and he
goes dear david
this is my candlelight and he starts
dotting it with the [ __ ] but he wrote
it through like a facebook message or
something and then he kind of needed to
get something off of his chest
and basically what he wrote just in
summation he was saying that
when i moved to la he was expecting me
to take
uh him me take him with me and i was
like first of all [ __ ]
who what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you grown ass [ __ ] man
yeah i was supposed to take you with me
with what
money were you guys supposed to be
partners or some
in his mind he created this whole
narrative about us being successful
together so you backstabbed him it's
like no bro we're both we're both
supposed comics yeah you do your thing i
do my thing if we do stuff together
things pop off i never had this
responsibility
of bringing you up with me because i
because i gained more fame
yeah like yeah i'm down to help you out
so you guys did comedy together back in
not even together it was just we were
just
buddies you know and first of all we
weren't even that close
like we really weren't like the only
time we met up is to do comedy like
comic stuff
together like stand up right maybe it
was special to him
he lived in his own [ __ ] world that's
crazy and so you know
we had a goodbye thing i was like amen
i'm going to move to la i'm going to
pursue this stuff
and he just kept it in yeah he was upset
because i didn't say hey you should move
with me
like [ __ ] i'm worried about my kind of
thing you're entitled to to my hard work
you know and so when i when i left
it was like three or four years later
and you know he kind of wrote this whole
long diatribe he goes
i hadn't talked to this dude in a while
he kind of just disappeared on me right
and i just kind of assumed you know he's
out doing his stand-up grind i
i switched over to youtube yeah so maybe
he's doing being really successful
instead oh offensive dude
yeah you didn't [ __ ] help me yeah
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and so
this guy in the letter he basically
wrote that
it was kind of like a backhanded
compliment which already ticked me off
you know and he goes well you know i i
see that you're doing well you're doing
big things out there blah blah blah
and i was first happy because i haven't
heard from him from him in a while
he goes i'm out here in the bay area
doing stand-up he goes i'm killing it
out here
all this other stuff and i'm like it's
so funny when people say that i'm
killing it you should see me
yeah which already was a weird weird
part in that in that letter that he
wrote and he goes i just want to tell
you that i
was a little offended that you didn't
take me with you when you went to l.a
which i was like what the [ __ ] does that
mean [ __ ] are you my son
are you my child you grown ass [ __ ]
man plus boy
and he was basically saying i wish you
would have taken me but i was a little
i'll be real with you i haven't talked
to you because butt hurt about that
i was like i thought you were just doing
your thing i thought you were just doing
stand-up and everything was good
and what a week and here's the the worst
part of the letter that pissed me off
and this is what i had to write back to
him because i was so mad
he wrote yeah i just want to say that
you know i know that you popped off and
things are going great for you but i'm
you know i'm writing scripts i'm writing
films and whatever what not and
you know i'm going to do big things and
i just want to say that even though you
popped off i don't think that meant that
ever meant that you were a better comic
than me
like i think i was better than you but
you just had a better opportunity
which i don't know why he wrote that why
is he competing with you like i didn't
know and
by the way let you know i'm [ __ ]
better than you i was mad supportive of
him right yeah even though he sucked
like i could i might be able to find
someone to stand up on youtube yeah and
you will be like this is the worst
stand-up comic on earth and i was still
mad supportive of him yeah and so i was
like okay cool
so i just wrote back to him i was like
number one
cool i'm glad that you're doing well
number two i said
you're not a better comic than me if you
were a better stand-up comic than me
then you would be where i'm at right now
but you're not and you're still
waiting tables doing [ __ ] so when
you when you get to my [ __ ] level
[ __ ] when you get to my and i've never
stunned it on somebody like this right
but when you get to my [ __ ] level you
let me know that we could have this
conversation yeah and i just ended it
that way
it was such a rude disrespectful thing
to say like i've never thought ill about
this guy and but this is what i'm
talking about
like you just never know who's hating on
you yeah you're just breathing and
you're just like well i don't know man
we have a lot of them in the comments
too
it was such an odd thing because i was
always supportive of him i just never
gave him handouts like
i never give anybody [ __ ] handouts
right if we work together we're
collaborative
i'm not here to hold your coward because
if i felt that
i was backstabbed by you or hurt or
whatever i would
text you and be like david can i talk
like dude i thought we were going to l.a
together like what's going on like
like do it immediately why is he waiting
four years
four years and he's still thinking about
it he's probably telling all these
people like
you know what david did me dirty man
yeah and it's like
what okay i'm glad see this is the thing
is like
aren't you glad when you find these
things out about people that you
left them in the dust right why do
people hold on to people like
you're holding on to a lot of trash is
what i'm saying it's like
there's so much gold out there there's
so many great human beings right
and i see people feeling like they're
not gonna be able to replace
this person or they're gonna be lonely
but it's like
for example imagine if you stayed in in
sacramento and you you stayed friends
with this person or acquaintances
and then you held them and you know you
didn't want to come to l.a because you
you were afraid to like
[ __ ] offend this dude
right because maybe you found out from
someone that he didn't want you to go to
la because he's not going
right and then you made your life
decision on this and a lot of people
make this [ __ ] mistake it's the same
thing that hurts people so bad because
they feel like they don't want to hurt
somebody they don't want to be an
[ __ ]
they don't want to be selfish and all
these things right but this
[ __ ] is actually hurting your future
in your career imagine if you didn't go
and you didn't meet us and you didn't
find other friends and build new
memories with new people and all that
like
it would it would have you would have
probably been working at the men's
warehouse still
yeah no i don't know you know but that's
what i'm saying taking over your parents
it's like business i don't know would
that person have been happier
if i just stayed in sacramento right and
just
been busting tables with him for the
rest of his life it's like first of all
dude
he misses the friendship yeah you sound
like an abusive [ __ ] boyfriend yeah
you you [ __ ] scumbag yeah and i just
was so
taken aback by what he wrote you know
because in my mind
even though i hadn't talked to him in a
while we were so busy doing our own
things like he doesn't even
i came here with literally 200 bucks to
my name yeah
that's all i had in my bank account i
sold everything to come here and it was
like
okay you could have done the [ __ ]
same and by the way he had more money
than me
because he was working he was working uh
busting tables and doing all this [ __ ]
he was getting good tips or whatever
he needed you to take i know it's like
if you wanted to come here you could
have
and so people had this skewed percep
like perception of
of what a reality to me it's it's he's a
coward and he was never going to be
successful
because a successful person would be
like oh [ __ ] you're going to la where
are you going to move to
and then they put themselves next to you
they'll be like let's be neighbors
let's [ __ ] do this together because
like for me that's what's always worked
out for me
and successful people are just kind of
invasive like they don't know that they
are but they're just persistent
yeah you know like they just go and be
like oh [ __ ] you're going well i'll
[ __ ] invite myself too because
two sacramento buddies right like [ __ ]
man it's gonna work out
yeah it wasn't just him too he was also
just a part of this group of another guy
too
and he you know i heard through somebody
else that he also felt that i just kind
of left him in the dust
and david made it and it's like bro
your concept of even made it i did i
still haven't quote unquote made it
you know so this is still a this is a
lifelong journey
and so the fact that you're trying to
hang on to my coattails which isn't much
coattails to hang on to in the first
place
is sad they wanted to be your kevin hart
entourage yeah
it's like dude i haven't even built
myself up yet yeah you know like this is
still a learning process for me i'm
still super
cool david and we've been [ __ ]
friends like we did the stand-up circuit
together
yeah and so the other guy too uh that's
funny he was somebody that i used to
like shoot youtube videos for when i was
learning how to use a dslr it was my
it was a canon 60d and i used to shoot
videos for him all the time for free
i was going to do it for money because
we were friends yeah and then
you know he later on i heard through the
grapevine he goes like yo like
you kind of forgot where where we came
from i'm like where we came from bro i
shot free videos for you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
thought that you were part of a crew
yeah and that you needed to move
together
or something like who was gonna do my
lightsabers for me
who's gonna do the editing the
lightsaber editing and
it was so dumb too and this is this is
why those two people are are cowards is
because
they felt this way for the longest time
and they never addressed this to me
and when they finally do or they they
never did one of them never did
and the other one did was facebook was a
facebook message
and they're they're actually really good
friends with each other well yeah
they're probably sitting there talking
[ __ ] about you all day
and this is what i tell people all the
all the damn time right like
a lot of people they hold a lot of
importance
of like what people think about them and
i'm like
if you spend your life just worrying
about what other people are gonna think
because this is the truth is there's a
lot of haters there's just
they're just out there because a lot of
people are insecure a lot of people are
weak
a lot of people are just not able to go
through life and take responsibility for
their actions and [ __ ] like that it's
just the way it is right
and if you lose to those thoughts
you actually spend all your time
thinking about how to defend against
them how to reason with them how to
convince them
that that's not who you are and guess
what before you know it
10 years passed by you didn't do [ __ ]
because you spent 10 years
trying to [ __ ] make sure that the
haters understood you
yeah so many people make this mistake
man
and to me i almost feel like it's an
addiction like
i don't know why people just don't see
the formula like the formula
is like you don't [ __ ] with it like this
these things exist people are just crazy
they have [ __ ] opinions
why do you have to like battle it out
yeah
just work on you and develop on what you
got to do
that's that's the thing too and you know
i bring up these stories only to mention
because i feel
i'm glad that i made the choice to come
out here right i'm glad that i made the
choice to kind of pursue what i needed
to do
because when we look back on it those
two people from what i've heard
they still aren't doing stuff in
entertainment yeah i know i hear from
people that people are still talking
[ __ ] about me from before
and it's funny because i'm just like
yeah but what do you got going on
yeah and that's that's the weird thing
for me right and when i hear that
i get not even sad irritated because
like i'm over here like a dumbass
thinking great things about you you
[ __ ] dick and it's like we were
friends in my head and then i find out
that you never liked me and
what the [ __ ] but this is where we
mentioned before on this podcast where
people will sometimes only like you if
you stay at the level that they're at
and if you go above them suddenly they
think that you're better than them
and that's not it you chose not to
elevate yourself i can't wait around for
you yeah and i'm always gonna
i'm i have to look out for myself first
yeah
not in the sense of i'm gonna do stuff
to step on people to get my own way
i'm gonna make my own path right and you
should make your own path too i'll never
step on somebody to get to where i need
to be
but i'm gonna create the path that's the
best for me right
if you're not gonna come along that way
i can only suggest like hey
let's work on your [ __ ] too let's work
on this together but if you're expecting
me to hold your hand all the way through
you're going to drown me i know right
and it's funny because i'm always
offering
like i'm an open book like anybody that
wants to talk or whatever like i'm
i'm there but the funny thing is right
like people that in my past
they don't want to take that offer like
it's easier for them to just
sit down and talk [ __ ] or whatever or
people that have never even met me at
all
like i mean we all have haters like
and that blows my mind because i'm like
well you can hate me all you want but
hey man if you want to have a
conversation you want to learn like you
want to
see how i did it like instead of just
hating on what i drove or
what i bought or what i have or who i
[ __ ]
um i can just teach you how to do it so
you can go out there and get it for
yourself
yeah that's empowering that's fun to do
and it's and nobody's crazy
nobody's gonna do it for you you know
just what like those two people who used
to be really good friends of mine
they expected somebody to be successful
for them
yeah and it hasn't worked out for them
they're they're freeloaders man
yeah they wanted to freeload their way
to success
and they chose the wrong person somebody
who's very aloof like me
i didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
you know i literally had no [ __ ] clue
yeah
damn i [ __ ] forgot about that guy but
that was one of those moments where i
was so taken aback
because um i i would always say great
things about him
you know even even when his stand-up
sucked his standard was his stand up was
[ __ ]
hot trash like just to put it in just to
put it in perspective he used to open up
with the stupid stand-up bit he was an
asian dude
and he would talk about how small his
dick was
the worst the worst [ __ ] thing to do
ever
and just watching him do that and just
people being like yo but what the [ __ ]
are you doing you know
and he just kept on doing that opening
[ __ ] bit talking never learn
never [ __ ] learn and it was like my
stand-up's getting better i was like no
it's not nobody laughed
nobody is getting better because i'm
saying the same thing but now i said it
a thousand times yeah there's a lot of
people who kind of
they do stand up in a very weird way and
i i say
uh if you want to do stand-up this is
not somebody who's a successful stand-up
comedian this is like me
saying being in these clubs and watching
people who i think are really great
and i'm not bad at it but i'm not great
so
there's some people who are funny and
there's some people who i call it they
they learn stand-up comedy like it's uh
like it's from a book
yeah they're just robotic exactly so
they go so when you do a joke you do
this this and this don't be that comic
yeah and that's what the comic that he
was he kind of read a book about how to
do stuff how to be funny
exactly and if you need a book on how to
be funny you're
probably not funny yeah i don't know
like it like you you talk to these guys
you have a conversation with them
you know in in the green room or
whatever you're just chopping it up
and they're just like the most unfunny
human beings i've ever met in my life
it's like how is their standup gonna be
funny and you see them go on stage
and they're the most unfunny [ __ ]
comics the joker they do stand-up comedy
sets
right yeah they do the the the intro the
setup the punch line
but it sucks right so and you could
always tell that in conversation when
you talk to these people i'm like oh
you're just not a really funny person
there's no heart
yeah there's no heart there's no
perspective there's no thought yeah it's
what it is
yeah well guys uh that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain
podcast uh joe plug in your 90 days to
freedom
90 days to freedom it's out right now um
like i said uh if you're watching on
youtube
um i'm gonna have a link in the
description you can click that
it's gonna take you to a video you can
watch that it'll explain
everything it's really amazing you guys
gotta just
see it for yourselves and also um if
you're listening
then go ahead and type in 90 days to
freedom
and my name joe jitsukawa
bing bao well guys we'll see you all
next time and have a blessed day
if you have haters in your life [ __ ]
them don't let people drag you down
[ __ ] them as well and if you meet a
pretty person
[ __ ] them as well that's the best all
right y'all peace
later